two bottles of vodka
is this gonna be the weekend we finally
meet six drink amy six drink amy what
does that mean it's the pinnacle of the
santiago drunkenness scale one drink
amy's a little spacey wait what
two drinks loud amy you want to get a
cab
three drinks amy dance pants
poor drink amy is a bit of a pervert
okay check it out
[Music]
and five drink amy is weirdly confident
let's do this little man
but i've never seen six drink amy maybe
she's the one i could actually be
friends with aka
my sasquatch
you ready to party or what i don't mind
if i oh
whoa
dang
ugh
you're two shots behind linetti
amy you got to be glad that holt's here
right i mean you're basically in love
with him i love him
i'm not in love with him but i'm
definitely not comfortable being drunk
around him james please keep the volume
down okay sorry it's two drinks i can't
help it that's it i'm cutting myself off
so jake messes up and you punish me for
it come on amy you're better than that
amy you don't have a drink oh no it's
okay i don't need the captain's making a
toast don't be rude prude okay i guess
i'll have one more you're on vacation
who's counting i am
even my fiery dance moves aren't keeping
me warm the trick is you got to be
prepared
mini cognac lady oh yeah
you don't want me up you little bastard
more drinks
thank you terry's fanny and thank you
poseidon
great god of the streets
[Music]
are you wearing
a t-shirt
i only brought a bikini it seems weird
to be in front of the captain a bathing
suit got to cover up them bangs yeah
fyi you can still see them for your
shirt boyle rosa and amy you're up come
on get on it and under it bangarang damn
sam games
you don't want to be around holt in your
current state
say hello to the most confident woman
alive
drink number five
you
are a true friend
and a hot little piece
goodbye forge rank amy sloppy sicko
his name is
blair underwood the man that's on the
grocery store is blair underwood hey ray
it's time
for
what detectives out of juggle you to
give me a promotion and a 40 raise
i've been carrying the squad for two
years
and my back's getting tired yeah excuse
me captain hey amy can i talk to you for
one second uh you just did burn oh so
good so listen i don't think
overconfident amy is working out maybe
you should go back downstairs oh maybe i
should just have another drink get ready
america here comes slicks
okay that's
six drink amy
so alone oh
no
six drink amy isn't fine she's just sad
damn it guys this is really bad ames
gina
you got to see the sasquatch was it
everything you dreamt it was the stuff
drums are made of can you hold my eyes
still till things stop spinning okay
let's set you up air easy there oh there
you go now drink this entire glass of
water
you're taking care of me just cause i
know you won't remember it
nope
you like me six drink amy is your friend
and and she's
gonna be very sick right now okay here's
what uh we are all about one free hotel
rooms i get to sleep in a bed by myself
no wife no kids just terry starfishing
on a cow king two a huge hall full of
cool police tech last year i got to try
out a heat ray three the buffalo pd
always throws an insane party last year
amy got so drunk she jumped a police
horse into the pool ate drink amy is an
equestrian and she's real bad at it
four hours left i'm down 58 dollars amy
where are you at four drinks what's four
drinking me again why don't you come
over here and find out right horny amy
it feels like you should retire that one
for the meteorology come over here make
me
all right there's only one thing left to
do drink faster set a bunch of fires
throughout the city mine's better no
we can do this
things seem bleak now but the night is
always darkest before the dawn
this is shaw's
we've had weddings here
in funerals
shaws is part of our family
because that is what we are
a family
and we're not just amy and rosa and
hitchcock and school
oh
man it's over we need a miracle i'm here
kim no how are you here you called me
you didn't stop calling me i didn't call
you
look you left 17 voice mails here's one
hoax you got to come save us we need a
lie to get you here charles what should
i say that i got shot in the face oh and
tell him to bring pizza whoa creme hoe
we're losing yeah
why are you dancing oh i was up to 900
gaming who speaks french
and then i heard
a girl her what she was trying to say is
that she vomited and now she's back down
to three drink amy or amy dance pants
you know it
oh my god hitchcock are you the only
person still making sense yeah
it's bad you thought you could distract
me with a record deal please i'm already
represented by my mom god you're a turd
well this turd is your best friend's
future husband
doink hey wait no give that back to me
he's gaming on you not for long
free shots for everyone
[Applause]
bye-bye connie tell your mother i said i
never loved you and that your whole
family is a bunch of friggin
oh
[Music]
never have i ever slept with a guy
broken his heart hired him to play at my
wedding stole an illegally binding
contract from him jumped on a bar dump
booze on everyone falling off the bar
probably giving myself a concussion and
a permanent scar i have ever
well it is officially after midnight so
i can now say whatever i want uh-oh
tonight
was awesome and i loved hanging out with
you dorks
you know the word dork is actually a
celtic word meaning lungfish kylie i'm
trying so hard i'm feeling a little
awkward yeah me too
how do we make it not weird
i know
let's just get super drunk yes great
idea pardon me ma'am could you please
bring us four kamikaze shots and four
for me as well ah i like your style see
we can do this we're back on track we're
keeping it light and breezy
so
we broke a rule
yeah
i hope it wasn't a mistake
hope it wasn't a mistake title your sex
tape
title of our sex tape
you